>> Tucker: KANYE WEST GAVE A
LONG STREAM OF CONSCIOUSNESS
TALK IN THE WHITE HOUSE RECENTLY
AND WAS ROUNDLY ATTACKED FOR IT
BUT IF YOU LISTEN CAREFULLY
THERE WERE SOME INSIGHTFUL POINT
THAT HE MADE IN SOME IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS, INCLUDING WHETHER
BLACK AMERICANS OUGHT TO BE
MONOLITHICALLY LOYAL TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WHY SHOULD THEY BE?
THAT'S THE QUESTION OTHER PEOPLE
ARE ASKING AS WELL, FOUNDER AND
PRESIDENT -- SUGGESTING THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE MOVED LEFT ON
RELIGION AND SOCIAL POLICIES,
EVEN THE RULE OF LAW ITSELF.
THEY COULD CONTINUE TO ALIENATE
SOME CONSERVATIVE MINDED BLACK
VOTERS.
STAR PARKER JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
SIMPLE QUESTION, FIRST, WHY
SHOULD AFRICAN-AMERICANS WHO FOR
GENERATIONS HAVE BEEN VERY LOYAL
TO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY RETHINK
THAT LOYALTY?
>> THEY'VE BEEN LOYAL TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BECAUSE BLACKS
HAVE BOUGHT THIS IDEA OF
ACTIVIST GOVERNMENT BUT
SOMETHING VERY EXCITING IS
HAPPENING NOW WITH TRUMPING
OFFICE, THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
IS FOCUSING ON URBAN COMMUNITIES
AND INITIATIVES SO WE HAVE TWO
THINGS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
THERE ARE VERY EXCITING.
IF NUMBER ONE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
MILLENNIALS, KANYE WEST HAS
MOTIVATED, THEY SAY WAIT A
MINUTE, WHAT HAVE DEMOCRATS DONE
FOR US?
FIRST OF ALL, THE MILLENNIAL
DOES NOT BUY THIS RACISM BEHIND
EVERY ROCK NARRATIVE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BECAUSE THEIR
FRIENDS ARE DIVERSE.
THEY'VE GROWN UP IN A SOCIETY
POST-CIVIL RIGHTS ERA, SO THEY
DON'T KNOW THAT WORLD AT ALL.
BUT SECONDLY, THERE
INDIVIDUALIST.
THEY LIKE UNIQUENESS.
WE CAN SEE THEM IN THE TATTOOS
THAT THEY WEAR.
SO THIS IDEA OF COLLECTIVISM AND
BIG GOVERNMENT DOESN'T WORK FOR
THEM AS WELL BUT WAS ALSO HAPPEN
IS YOU HAVE THE BABY BOOM BLACK.
MORE TRADITIONAL IN THEIR
WORLDVIEW, SO NOW THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY HAS BECOME SO EXTREME TO
THE LEFT, SO PROGRESSIVE THAT
ITS CONFLICTING WITH THAT BABY
BOOM BLACK WORLD VIEW VALUES AND
THEY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR
GRANDCHILDREN AND WHAT THEY'RE
LEARNING IN SCHOOLS, SO WE WILL
SEE WHILE IT ALL PLAYS OUT.
OUR GROUP IS LOOKING VERY
CLOSELY AT WISCONSIN, MICHIGAN
WHEN WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
SENATE SEATS, GOVERNOR SEATS, WE
SHOULD ALL BE LOOKING AT
GEORGIA, WE SHOULD LOOK AT
FLORIDA AND EVEN TO SOME DEGREE
MARYLAND.
I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
MOMENTUM.
>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE AN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTER AND YOUR
FAMILY HAS BEEN IN THIS COUNTRY
FOR 400 YEARS, A LONG TIME AND A
LOT OF CASES AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
YOUR PARTY IS TELLING YOU THAT
THE REAL CONCERN IS PEOPLE WHO
AREN'T EVEN HERE ILLEGALLY,
FOREIGN NATIONALS FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES, DO YOU ASK YOURSELF
AT SOME POINT BUT WHAT ABOUT ME,
THE AMERICAN CITIZEN?
DOES THAT TURN OFF VOTERS AT A
CERTAIN POINT?
>> IT'S NOT ONLY TURNING THEM
OFF THAT THIS HIJACKING OF THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT IS TAKING
PLACE FOR LEGAL MINORITIES, BUT
ILLEGAL FOR A LESSER EVEN MORE
FRUSTRATED BECAUSE NOW YOU ARE
LOOKING AT AN ENVIRONMENT TO
WHERE YOU HAVE THAT LOW-WAGE
WORKERS COMPETING FOR JOBS AND
COMMUNITIES AND AGAINST PEOPLE
WHO WILL NOT SPEAK ENGLISH, SO
IT'S NOT ONLY AFFECTING THE REAL
LOW-WAGE, IT'S AFFECTING THE
MIDDLE-CLASS BECAUSE IF YOU WANT
TO WORK IN ANY TYPE OF PUBLIC
SERVICE FOR THE FIRE, FOR THE
POLICE, FOR THE TEACHERS,
ANYTHING, YOU HAVE TO BE
BILINGUAL AND THIS IS MAKING A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, WE THINK WITH
THESE NEW ARRIVALS ARE.
>> Tucker: I THINK IT'S A
TOTALLY FAIR QUESTION.
I NEVER EVEN THOUGHT ABOUT THE
BILINGUAL QUESTION.
>> IT'S HORRIBLE.
IN CALIFORNIA FOR INSTANCE YOU
CAN TAKE THE DRIVER'S LICENSE
TEST AND 40 LANGUAGES.
>> Tucker: I NEVER HEAR MAXINE
WATERS OR ANY MEMBER OF THE CDC
MENTIONED THAT.
WHY?
>> THEY ARE VERY INVESTED IN
PROGRESSIVISM.
IT'S THEIR JOB TO MAKE SURE
BLACKS DO NOT GET ANY OF THIS
INFORMATION.
THE WHOLE CONGRESSIONAL BLACK
CAUCUS -- THEY HAD TO MAKE SURE
THAT NO GETS ANY INFORMATION OF
FREEDOM AND THAT'S BEEN THERE
ROLE FOR THE LAST 50 YEARS.
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW IS PEOPLE
ARE GETTING MORE INFORMATION.
MY ORGANIZATION, WE HAVE OUR OWN
NEWS SITE.
A BLACK COMMUNITY NEWS.COM SO
PEOPLE ARE GETTING OTHER SOURCES
OF NEWS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID LATELY
ABOUT FAKE NEWS IS VERY REAL.
THERE ARE MANY INSTRUMENTS NOW